a court in hong kong has convicted seven
prominent pro-democracy activists and
politicians for their role in
anti-government protests in 2019.
two other defendants had previously
pleaded guilty now these defendants they
included the man known as hong kong's
father of democracy
martin lee he is the 82-year-old founder
of the democratic party
also 73-year-old media tycoon jimmy ly
he's one of the most outspoken critics
of the current administration
and margaret ung a 73 year old former
lawmaker
nearly every leading voice of opposition
in hong kong is now
in jail on trial or in exile dw's phoebe
kong met up with activist lee check
young
before the verdict for a look at the
decades-long
democracy struggle against beijing
a small flat in downtown hong kong where
the world's only museum dedicated to the
1989
tiananmen crackdown is located the
military repression in beijing
32 years ago changed the course of many
people in china
and hong kong including lee check in
i was there during the june 4 massacre
and i was detained for three days
after my release back to hong kong i
pledged that i would spend my lifetime
in fighting for the democracy in china
and so that those who sacrifice
will not be in vain decades on
lee che gen is facing a different fate
critics see another massive crackdown
being carried out by beijing
this time on its most liberal and
democratic city
hong kong in the wake of anti-government
protest
he and eight others were charged for
organizing and attending an unauthorized
assembly
that rally in which over a million
people took part
was one of the few without violent
clashes
every one of the defendants are profile
figures
apart from media tycoon jimmy lai or are
former lawmakers or icons of the
opposition movement
like martin lee who is known as father
of democracy
each of the charges carries a maximum 5
year jail term
this case is just a tip of the iceberg
with over 10 thousand others arrested
for lee choi yang is the first verdict
among the nine
charges for which he's on trial
beijing's recently imposed sweeping
national security law
and his overhaul of the city's electoral
system intensified the fear
leech yen organized hong kong's cinnamon
morning vigil every year
calling for an end to china's one-party
rule for decades
an act that could make him a prime
target and beijing's security law
this year he will likely be absent for
the very first time
in this era in a way that going to jail
is part of the struggle now
i would comfort myself by saying that
this is already
something of a blessing for me that i
would only have to go to jail after you
know 40 years of activism
in hong kong and but i'm ready to pay
the price and ready to face it
having witnessed hong kong's
decades-long struggle the 64-year old
activist
is not optimistic for he believes that
his successes will continue the fight
for democracy
until they finally reached a goal
and for more on this let's bring in
nathan law pro-democracy activist from
hong kong and former student leader
joining us from london where he
is in exile nathan thanks for joining us
on the program today uh you know those
who have been convicted
they are veterans of the pro-democracy
movement what is your reaction to these
verdicts and
what do you think it means for them
um so this case is just one of
the case in such a massive suppression
um we've got
we've already got 47 uh prominent
experts being arrested under the
national security law
and um these seven defendants they're
all my
friends and um great athletes
contributed a lot on hong kong's
democratic movement and um this is
definitely a political persecution that
they are being completed because of
peace of assemblies
okay so you call it a a a political
persecution as you mentioned this is
just
one of uh or rather a few of several
cases that are before the court system
um i'd like to ask you about the others
that are as well for example the 47
pro-democracy politicians and activists
who have been charged with subversion
under the new security law
for participating in an election primary
that
prosecutors say was part of a plan to
subvert the government
do you think they will also be convicted
well we have to understand the nature of
the national security court
the government can pack their judge
there is
no jury available and the government
could choose to
conduct the hearing without any presence
of the public
so if you look into the condition of
that
and you look into the ordinance of the
national security law which is written
really quickly
and that is literally a large room for
interpretation
by the judge and by the courts so i
think uh the possibility of them being
convicted
is actually quite high so
i think this is another example of how
the government uses
the national security law to push some
dissident voice and the world should
continue to pay attention to it
given that nathan put it into the big
picture for us
what does it mean for the pro-democracy
movement what does it mean for the legal
system
so for now the the protein muscle c
movement
has stepped into a low types it's like
we're stepping into a winter storm
that every one of us has to face it and
um possibly the people tends to light
low
but if someone is still resisting they
will receive
serious repercussion but i don't think
that will
kill all the determination of us
fighting for democracy
i think many of us have already uh
been jailed and see it as uh one
of the cost that we have to pay on the
role of struggle
so i think many of them actually have
the mental
preparation for that and for the rule of
law in hong kong it's all gone
under the national security law and
people's freedom of expression and
freedom of association
are being all annihilated so i think
that is a sad
reality of hong kong and nathan these
seven convictions that we've seen today
they come amid efforts by china to only
allow quote patriots to be part of the
legislature
you know beijing and these pro-beijing
lawmakers
for their part they say that the
pro-democracy camp has been disruptive
on the streets disruptive in the
legislature
where things could no longer get done
how do you respond to that
the pursuit for democracy is completely
legitimate um
in 1997 when hong kong was handed back
from the british government to the
chinese government
the chinese government promised hong
kong people
that we will gradually get our democracy
and it should have happened
um five to ten years ago so for now
i think um beijing has always been
trying to
use these excuse to conceal the fact
that they're breaking promise breaking
international treaty
and they are depriving hong kong people
from their legitimate rights
and they're using legal persecution to
silence us
once again so um i think it is important
that
the world understands the direction of
the protest behind hong kong people
and also um well seeing these
all these persecution as another wave of
human resolution from china and try to
hold them accountable
thank you so much for joining us nathan
law pro-democracy activist from hong
kong former student leader
on this day where as we have mentioned a
court in hong kong
has convicted seven prominent
pro-democrat democracy activists nathan
thank you for sharing your view thank
you
you